once upon a time there was a dragon
named seath who was a bit of an ugly
duckling
his brothers all made fun of him so he
betrayed them and was rewarded by gwyn
seath had a thing for gwyn's daughter
gwynevere and one day he stuck his
crystal halberd into her gaping dragon
nine months later a child was born
priscilla
once priscilla had grown to adulthood
many of the gods realized that she was
incredibly cute
she had a tail so fluffy that no mortal
could resist petting it
the gods recognized that she would bring
many many many one-quarter dragon babies
into the world
and locked her away the painted world is
essentially a giant chastity belt
but some adventurers could not resist
priscilla's allure and journeyed into
the painted world
looking for their waifu their corpses
were left as a warning for adventurers
go back go back but alas adventurers
could not go back because the exit was
actually behind priscilla
kind of pointless really why use them as
warnings inside a place you can't even
leave
anyway finally the chosen undead
fulfills his mission
every trial has led him here and now he
can claim his prize
he can now caress the tale of priscilla
many people believe that the true ending
comes when you defeat gwyn
but this is the real ending
thou must returneth whence thou came
this land is peaceful
it's inhabitants kind but thou does i'm
sorry what
this land is peaceful it's inhabitants
kind
are you [ __ ] kidding me you mean
these guys
[Music]
its inhabitants
yeah i guess they sure are fond of my
souls